la tension monte d'un cran après la
rhétorique du Kremlin Moscou va déplacer
des armes nucléaires tactiques chez son
allié Bélarus aux portes de l'Ukraine et
de
l'otana
Poutine se prépare à utiliser ses armes
nucléaires selon la Maison Blanche qui
se montre rassurante la doctrine
nucléaire américaine basée sur la
dissuasion demeure inchangée insiste
John Kirby
e pas l'Union européenne aux portes du
théâtre ukrainien se tient prête à
répondre avec de nouvelles sanctions a
répondu le chef de la diplomatie
européenne Joseph Borel
Vladimir Poutine a déclaré samedi que 10
avions Bélarus ont déjà été modifiés
pour transporter les ogives des missiles
capables de frappe nucléaire ont aussi
été transférés chez l'Allier de Poutine
Moscou promet de conserver le plein
contrôle de ses armes même hors de ses
frontières
le Belarus de Lukachenko redeviendra
ainsi l’hôte de l'arsenal nucléaire
russe pour la première fois depuis la
chute de l'Union soviétique rien pour
rassurer l'Ukraine le Kremlin a pris le
Belarus en otage nucléaire selon le
secrétaire du Conseil de sécurité
ukrainien la Russie qui brandit la
menace nucléaire depuis des mois à
suspendu le mois dernier le traité de
désarmement nucléaire new start signé
avec les États-Unis ici Jean-Philippe
news Radio-Canada Montréal